From Guillermo del Toro, the Latino Peter
Jackson, comes a completely original sci-fi
universe that doesn't rely on any pre-existing
franchise.
... as long as you don't count Transformers,
Ultra Man,
Power Rangers,
Godzilla,
Rock 'Em Sock 'Em Robots,
that stupid Hugh Jackman robot boxing movie,
or every anime ever made.
Pacific Rim.
When giant aliens emerge from this iTunes
visualizer at the bottom of the ocean, the
entire world's resources will be spent on
building giant robots to punch them in the face.
But these machines are only as good as their
two pilots, who for no reason at all must
be connected by an overly-complicated neural
bridge to ensure drift compatibility,
a system so advanced only family members can
do it.
"You are drift compatible."
Or just two random strangers.
"We are drift compatible."
Or just one guy by himself.
This makes no sense - but it sure looks cool!
Meet Raleigh Becket, a hot-shot pilot struggling
to maintain his American accent
"All those years I spent living in the past,
I never really thought about the future."
And his co-pilot, Mako Mori, a girl so bad
at speaking English
"I've studied your fighting techniques and
strategy."
sometimes she just gives up mid-sentence.
"You promised me!"
Watch as these two awkwardly flirt in the
classic will-they-won't-they relationship.
Then, for the first time in movie history...
WON'T.
Suit up with these bad ass fighting robots.
"Crimson Typoon."
"Cherno Alpha."
"Striker Eureka."
And this one named after a stripper.
"Gipsy Danger."
Who comes fully-equipped with
ineffective elbow rockets,
painfully slow plasma canons,
and an incredibly powerful sword they forgot
they had until about two thirds of the way
through the movie.
... Probably should've busted that out at
the beginning of the movie. Don't you think?
Ride along with a Marshal, an ex-pilot
forced to take cancer-causing future Altoids
but no amount of future cancer can stop him
from giving the most awesome speech since
Independence Day.
"Today we face the monsters that are at our
door and bring the fight to them. Today we
are canceling the apocalypse!"
[cheering]
Hell yeah!
So relive the summer's guiltiest pleasure
that's either the most awesome dumb movie
ever made
or the dumbest awesome movie ever made.
So awesome!
So dumb!
Starring...
things your inner 9-year-old will love
giant robots
giant monsters
giant robots punching giant monsters
using shipping crates as brass knuckles
using a freighter like a baseball bat
bo staff fighting
colors!
a doggy!
aw, that's got three arms!
pew pew pew!
whoa!
and that one part...
where he's all like "Ugh"...
and the Kaiju's all "Rarr!"
Awesome Dumb Robot Movie
ummm...
Pacific Rim
Let's be honest: that movie was super dumb.
But I still cannot wait for the sequel.
Thanks for watching.
Be sure to subscribe.
"Only YOU can prevent forest fires."
"60% of the time, it works every time!"
"I'm not locked in here with you. You're locked
in here with me."
"I am a banana!"